oh well uh mini David was
um I think a really happy uh Happy Kid I
was really close to my older sister
Ellie we were just about you know a year
a little over a year apart
um uh yeah Barry I mean my parents were
both working lawyers but very present
parents um and I was I would describe
myself as very I was very happy very
hyperactive very physical very what they
would probably
um uh probably diagnose me with ADD
today but I was I was uh like
uncontrollable energy and
um uh and enthusiasm I guess so yeah um
uh I I would say in a nutshell that was
mini mini David and born in New York
when did you move to LA yeah born in
Queens New York
uh when I was about two years old my
parents who were native New Yorkers born
and raised Brooklyn and Queens they
you know they had the courage
um to follow their hearts and and leave
all of their very close family their
their parents their aunts and uncles all
my grandparents my great aunts and
uncles and my you know uh my aunts and
uncles we left everyone and moved to Los
Angeles where they were pursuing
opportunities as young lawyers
um luckily I would go back many times I
think around twice a year if at least to
see all those relatives who played a big
part in in our lives growing up so
excellent so Nick Leeds I think in the
80s is where you start what's mini Nick
Story how many Nick gosh um I think I
like David's description of probably
would have been diagnosed with ADD I
probably I might have as well I was
quite I I think I was probably like a
bit much sometimes I was really into
Magic from a very young age from when I
was about four years old and so you know
I would bother family and friends to you
know pick a card and show them pretty
Nast tricks and um uh I think so I was
probably a little bit
uh possibly a little bit precocious in
that respect but but a very a very happy
child
um I uh uh I knew from a quite a young
age I really enjoyed making people pull
laugh
um you know whether whether I was sort
of genuinely funny or whether they were
just sort of humoring me I think is much
to be debated but um but but yeah I you
know I went I went to you know very
normal primary school and secondary
school in Leeds my mum and dad my mum
they're both retired now but my mum was
a GP uh it was quite funny because she
was the doctor to some of my friends in
fact my best friend from from home uh
she was their family doctor which is
always quite quite amusing
um and and uh and my dad my dad had a
few jobs when we were growing up but he
he sort of settled in in sort of like
legal profession and was a solicitor
um uh for a good while when he and you
know he's now retired as well but yeah I
was you know I I guess
I didn't know that I was kind of going
to go into
comedy or acting at the time but I
definitely had a had a you know a
passion for for performing and I guess
maybe slightly being the center of
attention and um yeah music was quite a
big part of my life when I was growing
up as well I played piano and violin and
um uh yeah but I have very very fond
memories and obviously I haven't been
back home for a while because of the
pandemic but I you know I love going
back to Leeds and uh and yeah very very
fond memories
and it's interesting that you both had
lawyers as in in the parental sort of
setup
um and David I mean your sense of social
justice that came through them I think
was very important to you
yeah uh still is uh it was really really
formative growing up
um my parents were activists and
progressives and a lot of early memories
on picket lines with them and seeing
feminist theater that my mom was in and
blessed you know um yeah I was I was
thinking about this recently in a
conversation with with a friend of mine
but you know I I was born just two years
after the murder of
um these three
civil rights workers schwerner Cheney
and Goodman two of whom were young New
York Jews looked a lot like me so I I
and they were my parents age you know
when I was born so I grew up in this
with this very very
um hyper awareness not just of the
Holocaust but of the very present
reality of being Jewish in America and
um and anti-Semitism and that that I
think and you know when you grow up with
that kind of awareness that you are
other and that your life is literally at
stake or at in Jeopardy in different
parts of your own country in your own
backyard I think it informs your world
view in a huge way so that idea of being
um
you know of seeing any kind of Injustice
with any person of color or any kind of
discrimination was really profound as a
young person and kind of carried carried
through so
I know seeing live performance can often
be a big breakthrough moment for people
who go on to become performers
themselves and and David I think for you
being taken to the theater you see Ian
McKellen at 13.
well my parents had a love of theater
and every year we would on one of our or
both our trips back East to see family
we would make a point to see as many
plays and shows as possible you know I
remember a couple of trips we would see
like five shows within a six day trip to
you know so I was always going to
theater but my parents took me to see
Ian McKellen's one-man acting
Shakespeare in uh Westwood in like one
of the UCLA small theaters in Westwood
and I was just I was 13 years old and I
was completely
mesmerized and it was you know Nick
talks about magic I also was a fan of
magic growing up as a kid and the magic
that Ian McKellen like the magic trick
that he did of transforming himself
without any props or costume changes
into 25 of the greatest Shakespeare
roles written Men Women of different you
know sizes shapes I I was absolutely
awestruck and I thought I have to do
that magic trick I have to learn how to
do that
um so yeah I I was I was really bitten
by the bug quite early
Nick I was wondering with you you know
one there was a huge sort of you know
theater live performing scene in all
those great old theaters around you know
Leeds and Yorkshire
um but also magic I think had a real
growth there were all those people like
kind of Penn and Teller and David Blaine
who were kind of quite huge celebrities
by the the 90s what were you watching on
stage yeah definitely I think um yeah
yeah magic sort of had a real kind of
golden age I guess kind of going through
the late 80s with the Paul Daniels magic
show and then yeah completely with the
more
slightly more modern stuff or modern at
that time you know with the street magic
of David Blaine and some of the stuff
that was coming through from the states
like Penn and Teller the David
Copperfield specials and so on um in
terms of like live matching I mean I I
saw a lot of live live stuff yeah the
West Yorkshire Playhouse I remember
seeing magic shows at the Grand and the
Alhambra in Bradford
um
I think it you know there was a real
there was there was still uh I guess a
lot of performers who had had I suppose
cut their teeth at the the working Men's
Clubs in the sort of 70s and sort of
kind of going into the 80s
um you know who had a real kind of
stocking trade kind of act
um but who would frequently you know do
all the pantos up north and uh or you
know have their own have their own shows
and with some International supporting
acts and so yeah I got to see a lot a
lot a lot of stuff through
you know I'm you know similar to swim
you know my parents
didn't hold back in terms of we would be
taken to
you know as many things as I guess you
know we couldn't we could afford at the
time you know I remember seeing such a
mixture of things as well from musicals
to Shakespeare to Opera to magic shows
and um
yeah you know I would always sort of
take something or try try and take
something away from from all of them but
yeah getting to see I remember seeing
Paul Daniels a few times when I was
growing up live and um and he even as
recently seeing that Darren Brown's
first live show which was back in 2000 I
think or maybe even just before then uh
you know a good size theater but not a
massive massive theater in Bradford I
think Saint George's Hall it was maybe
um and just been completely blown away
I'd never seen that kind of branch of
magic or mentalism sort of performed in
that in that kind of honest way that you
know it's sort of his brand now and um
yeah it's wonderful to see that stuff
and I tell you jumping ahead to make a
connection but when you talk about the
magic here of seeing Ian McKellen do all
those Shakespeare characters you did a
one person Tempest didn't you oh yeah is
that do you think that's the feed of it
um
yeah I mean I I I was very lucky in the
high school I went to
um they had a really strong theater
program and I was introduced to
Shakespeare at a young age of you know
seeing Ian McKellen and my parents were
big fans of Shakespeare and um and so
there was this uh this competition and
I'm very competitive
um naturally so just so your eyes go
staring around yeah no when Nick knows I
think about anything I'm intensely
competitive
um so uh and I love games and sports and
all that stuff so anyway there was this
Shakespeare Festival in Southern
California of all the high schools in
Southern California would compete
against each other in two categories an
individual category where you would
represent your school
um or a scene a group category of like
four or five actors doing scenes from
anyway I cut together my own individual
Tempest where I played Prospero Ariel
and kylaban and I did this really
physical thing that Nick would probably
be genius at
um but transforming yourself at
different levels caliban on the ground
Ariel above and Prospero you know
whatever and I ended up winning first
place and uh you know in the competition
and the greatest moment of that that I
didn't know until you won was you get to
repeat and do your scene again in front
of all the schools
um on the main stage and I think doing
that at age like 14
you know was hugely formative because
um you know it was just this big thing
of approval it was like you hope you're
good but when you win something like
that you feel like oh okay I should
maybe keep doing this
others are enjoying it so sorry I was a
particular teacher for drama at your
school that this
took off with um Andy grineer uh was my
high school acting teacher that also
later uh introduced me to grotowski and
and a lot of this is a method is it yeah
very very physical theater method um and
philosophy and so I that was hugely
formative in in terms of then bringing
that to Northwestern and introducing a
kind of Yeah a different kind of style
and process that would eventually lead
to a formation of a whole Theater
Company later so we'll come to
University next but um fascinating Nick
as well because
teachers or certainly a teacher had an
impact on you that's scary yes I I sort
of I I'm it sort of got to the point now
where I feel I should just name them but
I've I've kind of Protected Their
identity so no I mean I'll be very
honest I don't even know if this person
is still is still alive you know we uh
she taught us English
um when I was doing My GCSE so yeah so
we were like 15 but she but she she left
I think she even went to a different
school or something but um she left sort
of halfway through our gcses but she
made an incredible impact and partly
because I mean she was genuinely such a
character and and it is you know
informed the character that I often do
on stage Mr swallow which is just
opinionated quite Camp
um individual with sort of huge
effectively she was sort of using her
position as a teacher uh as a platform
to just sort of just spout views about
literally you know anything and
everything and you know a bit Miss Jean
Brody I mean it's a long Heritage isn't
there yeah and I remember you know some
of the she once walked into a class the
classroom and was like right we're going
to do a debate and you know we're really
doing sort of English language or
something and I'm like oh okay and you
know she wanted to do a whole debate
about capital punishment and she
strongly but she was a strong advocate
for capital punishment and we were sat
there even at that age thinking well I
don't you know I think the debates may
be slightly more nuanced than that and
she you know she would have a go have a
go as if we if we disagreed with her
point of view but she was kind of she
just had this sort of amazing sort of
attitude and I don't know I just sort of
ended up using sort of doing impressions
of her at school and it kind of sort of
as I became a student and started doing
comedy gigs and so on it kind of crept
into uh my uh repertoire or whatever you
know I just started doing that voice for
Comic effect and so yeah she was an
incredible inspiration but uh I
shouldn't really name her because you
know I don't know she might not see it
as an homage it'd be like um that Carly
Simon thing you know who is the person
who's So Vain it's like who is Mr
swallow
um and I want to ask you both but Nick
Firth the role of University then where
you you know often people do really find
their voices performance
um Nick you went to Durham initially to
read geophysics and then started a PhD
in seismology studying earthquakes at
Cambridge
what what happened at University in
terms of you becoming you know the the
performer and the writer in there
i i as as much as I did you know a lot
of magic when I was growing up I still
wasn't
I was I was kind of confident in one
particular way but I wasn't really kind
of I didn't you know I wasn't sort of
experienced or kind of wise and I didn't
I didn't really know what I wanted to do
and and in some respects I think
Academia can feel quite quite an easy
option in that respect because you were
effectively told what to do you know I
went through you know Primary School
secondary school did Sixth form and then
and I thought well I'll do I'll go to
university and then you know I kind of
decided to do that PhD because I didn't
really know where else to to go and sort
of thought well I'll just keep on sort
of doing what I'm
you know I have been doing
um and and whilst I was at Durham
I knew that I enjoyed comedy and
certainly seeing it and uh and you know
listening to it and watching it on
television and so on and and there was
the student uh sort of comedy group was
the Durham review and uh and they they
only had auditions once a year and I
auditioned twice
um whilst Durham and didn't didn't get
in and so it didn't so much not my
confidence but it just made me think oh
well maybe it's not really for me but I
still had kind of lots of ideas and I
did I did the odd little gig whilst in
Durham but it was it was when I went to
Cambridge and the Cambridge Footlights
being you know the equivalent sort of
student comedy group what what was
brilliant about the Footlights certainly
then was that they I think even still
now actually but compared to Durham at
the time was that they did um you know
review shows every two weeks as opposed
to once a term and you know you could
effectively audition every two weeks and
so I just you know I remember thinking
well that you know just presented so
many more opportunities and
I I guess having had that period at
Durham where I I'd sort of been sort of
frustrated at maybe not really having
the outlet to sort of perform comedy
um suddenly there was there was far more
opportunities to do so at Cambridge and
and it took off a little bit from there
yeah fantastic and what about for you
David because you did a theater degree
at Northwestern and it struck me because
I I was that generation you know watched
Friends from the beginning and watched
you know all your films and I was really
struggling with intelligence you know
the sitcom you're done together had
technically skilled you are you know
there's timing there's physical movement
there's little moments of expression and
I remember thinking is that going back
to the degree
yeah it's going back it's a combination
of the degree at Northwestern and the
training there but also
since I was 13 years old every
opportunity I had to take
extracurricular theater and summer camp
and training I took so whether it's
clown school or I went to the British
America drama Academy at Oxford where
Brian Cox and rosemary Harris were two
of my teachers so and there was I was I
always was fascinated with the physical
comedy and and the kind of the training
and the dance and the movement that that
really went went hand in hand with it so
I tried to train everything and just
acquire as many skills as I could and
stage combat every everything you know
Northwestern really provided a really
strong Foundation there as well as these
other supplemental
opportunities I feel I've been waiting
25 years to ask you if you had done
something like Clan school just as I say
even in intelligence the way that you
you know you throw yourself across a
desk but it's a fool and it looks like
accident I just find that kind of
physical ability it's not something some
people ever learn and you were trained
in it years ago
yeah and and I kind of developed my own
process so uh because it really is for
me it's quite specific quite
choreographed and because in order to do
it over and over again you want to not
be hurt every time you do it so you want
to but you have to sell it as Nick knows
you have to sell it in a way whether
it's stage combat the same thing no one
you know no one ever wants to actually
get hurt
um so it's just it's just practice just
yeah yeah I'm glad you mentioned they're
not getting hurt because I thought
someone gets older as well it really
matters to do that well I'm saying
um
so there's a moment when you're both in
the same country which is David did you
bring a university show to Edinburgh
Fringe Festival
yeah um yeah so at Northwestern I had
always directed even in high school I
was directing
um and when I I got to Northwestern I um
I really wanted to direct this one very
physical production again kind of based
in grotowski but this adult version of
Alice in Wonderland and with six actors
transformed themselves and played every
character in the two books Alice in
Wonderland and Through the Looking Glass
with only one actress playing Alice the
entire time when he said adult I
misunderstood for a moment well it's
kind of a grown-up sophisticated version
of the adaptation of the two books
combined and it was first done by Andre
Gregory and the Manhattan Project in I
think the 70s but I really wanted to do
this and direct it at Northwestern but I
was told I hadn't taken the requisite
directing course with this one director
who I just hated his work I just thought
he was trash so I thought this is
completely illogical why do I have to
take directing why do I have to study
directing from him I've been directing
you know I was very full of myself but
um I've been directing since I was 13. I
don't like his work I don't see why I
have to do this so but they refused to
give me a space or support me directing
this play I said fine I'll use my bar
mats for money which I had saved and I
produced it I found a theater off campus
and I cast the show among you know
actors that I loved and respected and I
just produced it off campus it became a
really big hit and kind of like the hot
thing to see you know off campus and it
was successful on top of that and I
produced it as well as directed it and I
made money and I was like okay
so I being pretty as we've established
arrogant and full you know big-headed I
went to the dean of the school of speech
and I said hey um
you know I just produced this play off
campus I've heard about this
International theater Festival in
Scotland called the Edinburgh festival
and I think you should send me and the
cast to Enbrel to the festival to
represent Northwestern and the City of
Chicago like that I was so you know I
was 20 years old I didn't know what but
to his credit he said to me how much
does it cost and I'd done the budget it
was ten thousand dollars
and he said if if you raise half of it
I'll match it
and it was like done and so I got in
touch with Second City and I they gave
me a uh their space for free and I
produced the famous comedy club in
Chicago yeah and I I produced um a a
shortened version like benefit
performance to send us to Scotland and
sure enough we raised five grand and he
kept his word and that summer we were in
the Edinboro Fringe Festival where
I got to see Stephen berkoff's play West
the first time it was produced
and that play blew my mind
um and uh and I then spent the next 10
years trying to produce that in Chicago
with my company which he finally granted
us the rights to do but this is the
looking glass company that you set up
and which is still about this going but
that experience of producing going you
know you know traveling to that Festival
seeing all that theater from all over
the world and all over particularly all
over the UK the comedy seeing everything
it was and producing it successfully
like again was one of those formative
events that told me oh just keep doing
what you're doing so
do you know what it's also interesting
uh next thinking you know we know and
you would know that Edinburgh Fringe is
a kind of rite of passage for anyone who
wants to have a comedy career and it's
fascinating to see someone coming from
you know the states and it also becoming
a kind of it's almost like a station
that you both you went through it as
well presumably yeah absolutely very
much so yeah the first time I went there
was was with the Footlights and um
that was back in 2004 and then and then
the following many times over the years
yeah yeah and then the following years I
went every year
um but yeah I sort of then started doing
every other year 10 12 14 16 18 but um
uh 2012 25 not that odd
12 18 14 18. um
sort of where there's almost an
etiquette isn't there that if you you
know if you want to pursue comedy it's
work you know you absolutely go there to
road test your material it's a you know
the industry pretty much heads up to
Edinburgh over August obviously not at
the moment sadly but hopefully
if not this year next year it'll all
kind of be coming back again and you
know it's where you showcase your your
Year's worth of material and you know
the whole industry heads up there to see
what see what you're doing and what
you've done
um and could I say Nick you were robbed
for at least a couple of of nominations
I mean I was reading all the reviews of
your shows that you've taken to
Edinburgh
um and you know everyone was talking
about you and and I didn't have been
frustrating that perhaps Edinburgh
didn't give you the kind of break that
some people have had when they've won
you know what used to be the Perrier say
try not to kind of really get too
concerned by those things I mean there
are so many ways in which you can
I guess sort of have benchmarks in terms
of how how well you know how well you
feel you're doing in Edinburgh and
whether that's to do with ticket sales
or whether you're proud of the show or
whether your parents have liked it or
you know the press that you might get
critics liked you they raved about you
yeah they said why aren't you on the
show well I get I get you know and again
you gotta you gotta try and take some of
that with a pinch of salt but but yeah
you know listen it I I was just it's
always nice to do a show where you know
there's nothing more having more
recently done more TV comedy
um you there's something absolutely sort
of delicious about doing something which
feels quite Frontline when you kind of
put yourself on stage and you get that
absolute immediate response from an
audience and there is nowhere to hide
and you have to take I guess you know
the the the highs and lows there's no
there's no one else you can blame apart
from yourself and with TV you know there
is a process there are scripts or other
people who will you know who will want
input into those scripts and then
there's the process filming in an edit
whereas on stage you go on and of course
you prepare your material but you go on
there and you know immediately if the
audience like you or don't and and when
an audience do it's like no other
feeling and you know that that is worth
far more than you know any press or or
award nomination